girls will do a [ __ ] test is what they  call it is they'll make fun of a guy a  little bit and you want you don't know  this consciously but you're watching to  see how he reacts does he make fun of  you back does he kind of like play into  it or does he does he like get offended  and if he gets offended that's him  falling into your frame um yeah yeah  because he's thinking but we had to do  this historically because we had to make  sure the guy could protect us okay yeah  and so that's why if a guy kind of makes  fun of you like comes up to you and is  like what's wrong with that you're like  like you're kind of more interested  right but it's it's him because you're  going into his frame